Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we will try to create a copy of
ourselves, and place it into a virtual world.
Now this will be quite a challenge. Normally,
to do this, we have to ask an artist to create
a digital copy of us, which takes a lot of time
and effort. But, there may be a way out. Look.
With this earlier AI-based technique, we can take
a piece of target geometry, and have an algorithm
try to rebuild it to be used within a virtual
world. The process is truly a sight to behold.
Look at how beautifully it sculpts this piece of
geometry until it looks like our target shape!
This is wonderful, but wait a second. If
we wish to create a copy of ourselves,
we probably want it to move around too. This
is, however, a stationary piece of geometry.
No movement is allowed here. So,
what do we do? What about movement?
Well, have a look at this new technique,
where getting a piece of geometry
with movement cannot get any simpler than this
- just do your thing, record it with a camera,
and give it to the AI. And, I have
to say that I am a little skeptical,
look, this is what a previous technique could get
us. This is not too close to what we are looking
for. So, let’s see what the new method can do
with this data. And! Uh-oh. This is not great. So,
is this it? Is the geometry cloning dream dead?
Well, don’t despair quite yet! This issue happens
because our starting position and orientation
is not known to the algorithm, but,
it can be remedied. How? Well, by adding
additional data to the AI to learn from.
And now, hold on to your papers,
and let’s see what it can do now!
And…oh my goodness. Are you seeing what I am
seeing? Our movement is now replicated in a
virtual world almost perfectly! Look at that
beautiful animation. Absolutely incredible.
And, if even this is not good enough, look
at this result too. So good! Loving it.
And, believe it or not, it has even more coolness
up the sleeve. If you have been holding on to
your papers so far, now, squeeze that paper,
because here comes my favorite part of this work.
And that is a step that the authors
call scene fitting. What is that?
Essentially, what happens is that the AI
reimagines us as a video game character, and sees
our movement, but does not have an idea as to what
our surroundings look like. What it does is that
from this video data, it tries to reconstruct our
environment, essentially, recreating it as a video
game level. And that is quite a challenge. Look,
at first, it is not close at all. But, over time,
it learns what the first obstacle should look
like, but still, the rest of the level...not
so much! Can this still be improved? Let’s have
a look together. As we give it some more time,
and our character a few more concussions,
it starts to get a better feel of the level.
And it really works for a variety of
difficult, dynamic motion types. Cartwheels,
backflips, parkour jumps, dance moves, you name
it. It is a robust technique that can do it all.
So cool! And note that the authors of the
paper gave us not just the blueprints for
the technique in the form of a research paper,
but they also provide the source code of this
technique to all of us, free of charge. Thank
you so much! I am sure this will be a huge help
in democratizing the creation of video
games and all kinds of virtual characters.
And, if we add up all of these together. We
get this. This truly is a sight to behold.
Look! So much improvement just one more paper down
the line. And just imagine what we will be able to
do a couple more papers down the line. Well, what
do you think? Let me know in the comments below!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!